[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
roxrite is you know a little while ago
mr. Shawn contacted me thank you very
much in the spirit of if you like that
hold on thank you very much we'll be
starting relax Tamilian am about family
I would like to wish him and his family
I have the one blankie nervous
these miracles someone like me or not
[Applause]
and it starts of threads that we have
made with what people for the last
quarter hop use to see time to come on
the tiny evolution
and if we license managed to work hard
every day by dreams I have their
aspirations to get a job to get an
apprenticeship to start a business to
make this a bigger economy and to a
children
[Applause]
because it's always been about them it's
always waiting for those of you watching
this at home tonight for me and Omega
for all of my team it's all about you
tonight is not about me
Court is not about even the legal pad
tonight is about every single Australia
[Applause]
we'll come together I'll put this sock
and we will get back to work
[Music]
the dentist's wild onions with strategy
reminding the country to the other
I see that I was young too
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you in some boxes and I hope we'll
continue to be service invoice in a
number of these messes can I start off
by saying thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
under the stamp I do have to work time
to ensure that as a result of their
incredible efforts our I will be
returned tonight can I particularly fat
guys
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
Oh bollocks all of my necklace all of
you who worked so hard to get somewhere
within our bodies that we work for and
we serve and we do a comely and we do
any right appreciation
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the white
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Applause]
all together and we thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
together we need your good to have
people standing here bye-bye Annie my
Annie mold and you want to prosecute
upon as a little unnatural and
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that will be nice and secure
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]